now that you've seen the two other ways
of declaring and defining objects let's
give them a try by creating two objects
one using dot notation and the other
using bracket notation using dot
notation create an object that contains
some of your work information including
your position employer the years worked
in the city of the business then using
bracket notation create an education
object that includes the school you
attended the years you attended in the
school city and how well students know
they've done it right underneath your
objects append work brackets position
and education name to the resume if you
did it right they should show up